You did better than even I expected Maya
He taught her violence and fear.
Take your heart, Take your pain.
Make it into something useful.
It goes more towards a grounded series.
We wanted to toe the line.
Is Maya good or bad?
I'm excited for audiences to see how real this show is.
It's intense, man.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
Happy New Year
There's a whole bunch of big stuff coming up
Marvel just dropped a bunch of footage
of new Daredevil stuff inside Echo.
So of course, we'll break it down.
the entire series is going to be dropping Ben style
in a couple of weeks.
So I'll be doing videos for it
to be a little bit different
because they'll all be dropping at the same time.
but we'll finally be getting some classic daredevil
in kingpin in a way that we haven't gotten in the MCU
yet, even though they have both shown up in MCU
projects so far.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
This is the actual clip of Daredevil
just absolutely destroying Echo.
big thank you to the person
that actually captured this on TV.
They haven't released this online yet.
So it is a bit potato quality,
but it gives you a much better look at daredevil style
after the events of She-Hulk
and he is wearing the classic red costume.
It looks almost exactly,
if not exactly like the daredevil Netflix red suit.
doesn't that fight looks
so much better than the fight
that Daredevil had on the She-Hulk series.
That was meant to be a bit of a reference
to Daredevil's hallway fights
without actually being like a full on hallway fight
This time they're filming the fight
the way that you want them to film a daredevil fight.
Like long, continuous day, you could see the camera
panning around them as he just absolutely wrecks her.
so you can see the way that they handle
daredevil on the echo series
is a good preview of what Daredevil Born Again
is going to look like in why
they fall on rebooted Daredevil Born Again
like they've been making it for a little while.
Then the strike happened.
They had a pause, but then Kevin Foggy saw everything
they've been doing so far and was like, You know what?
Let's go back to ground.
Let's restart this and just do a much better job
of making a Daredevil series.
the scuttlebutt on daredevil born again
is that what they'd actually been doing
made it look a little bit more like a law and order
type of show like all those things
you saw of him in court during the She-Hulk series,
more of that and less of actual daredevil action,
the way you would want to see, like an action packed
series, kind of like the daredevil Netflix series.
season is kind of shocking to hear the.
Kevin Foggy hit that emergency button like,
no, no, no, stop right now.
We need to start again.
it sounds like their head is in the right place.
Like, No, no, no.
We could actually do a way better job
with the Daredevil character.
I also really love the fight
choreography here with his billy clubs any of that.
You don't really get a sense of it here.
You have to remember that one of her legs is also false
and super wicked, like she has a weapon in her leg.
So even though looks like she's fighting him without
weapons, she actually is fighting him with a weapon.
It just happens to be a really wicked prosthetic leg.
it also kind of looks like during this daredevil versus
echo fight,
he takes down a bunch of her men
to a bunch of Kingpin's other men.
Look at her. Taken five during their fight.
Two like she needs to catch your breath.
It's like going to take a minute
here, take a beat while this other person
gets their ass beat by Daredevil.
She likes the door to the cage in Daredevil
just flat out flips right over the cage
she grabs gun after a gun at gun and Daredevil
just keeps kicking them, punching them,
ripping them right out of her hands.
and it's all filmed in a continuous take.
the funny thing about Daredevil in the way
they film him like even though all those hallway
fights during the Daredevil Netflix series were bad
ass like they were amazing.
The funny thing about that is they actually revealed
that there were some cuts during those.
They were just hidden in a really,
really interesting way.
they were just clever enough to make them look like
they were all complete, continuous takes
that was probably one of the biggest complaints
about the Iron Fist series.
Like even though everybody Rags on Iron Fist,
it was just the way that they filmed that they just
need to do way better job with the fight choreography
that they sort of fixed when they got to the Sheng
Shi movie so they can actually do Iron Fist
on the level of say like the way they film.
Shang Shi I think will actually be in business
their fight is also meant to be
a reference to a lot of classic Daredevil comics
with Echo versus Daredevil.
the whole idea in the series is that their relationship
is pretty similar to what it is in the comics.
Also, her relationship with Kingpin, they just change
a couple of things about her backstory.
in the comics.
Kingpin had her father killed,
then basically took her and raised her as his own,
trained her as a weapon, and then lied to her, saying
that Daredevil killed her father,
then set her on Daredevil, like go kill him
in one of her special abilities,
Echo style, because of her name,
is that she could echo people's other abilities.
Copy them on the fly.
So she could match Daredevil move for move.
But they're not doing that ability on the TV show.
I believe they might actually be giving her actual
special powers through her Native American heritage.
she's meant to be a Choctaw Indian.
A lot of people were asking about this during the
What If series, Because the actress is playing Cody,
that brand new character, DeVry Jacobs, who has special
Tesseract Powers like Space Stone Powers,
is actually playing another character
on the Echo series Inside that Choctaw Nation.
That Echo goes back to where her hometown is.
but as far as I know,
everything that happened with that quality
character is not connected to what's happening on Echo.
It's a complete coincidence.
Really cool coincidence
though, and I do think that they will do the cohorts
character in live action eventually
Just because Avengers Six Secret Wars is so far,
like so many years out right now,
I think that's probably the best chance
for her to actually show up for the first time.
But it might happen in some other project.
DC has been doing that for a long time,
but Marvel just started doing that more and more like
Captain Carter is probably the best example
that we saw her during What If season one.
Then she showed up during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness in Live Action,
even though technically
that was a different version of Captain Carter.
Hayley Atwell
also implied that another version of Captain Carter
would show up in live
action again, like, that's not the last time we'll see
Captain Carter in live action.
So they did it with her.
They're probably going to do it with Gordy,
but none of that stuff is connected
with what's happening on Echo.
Echoes meant to be like a very grounded series.
So the powers that we do see on
the series will probably be
very ground level, like defenders level Netflix powers.
stuff that you saw on the level of Luke Cage, Jessica
Jones, Special Powers, Iron Fist, Special Powers,
even though it looks like Daredevil ends this fight
by throwing her through that wall into the skate rink,
that's part of another fight
when she's fighting one of the black knight cartel men
that come to the Choctaw Nation.
they're meant to be the actual main
villains of the Echo series.
Like what do you do in an anti-hero series?
You always put them up against somebody who's
even worse, and that is going to be the black knife
cartel from the comics.
they're actually from the Bulls eye comics,
even though I'm not expecting to see Bullseye
show up at any point during Echo,
maybe eventually during Daredevil, Born Again.
but at some point during echo
for whatever reason they wind up going
after Kingpin's territory in New York City.
end even though Echo basically rebelled against Kingpin
tried to kill him at the end of the Hawkeye
series, the idea is that the Black Knight
cartel comes for both of them separately.
So Kingpin and Echo kind of have to band together to
help each other take care of the Black Knight cartel.
inner wall that's going on, she reckons with her past,
with kingpin like you're kind of my other father.
You helped raise me and taught me the way of violence.
merrily theorize
that echo will be kind of like their daredevil season
for like sort of a warmup for actual daredevil
born again.
That'll be sort of like the next step
for those characters.
Most of the Daredevil Netflix series in
the Defenders series will be canon too.
What happens during that?
maybe a couple of minor changes.
Hopefully we get to see Foggy Nelson and Karen Page
because I think in the original version
before Kevin Foggy sort of like canceled,
then rebooted Daredevil born again,
I think that they started that series with Foggy Nelson
actually being dead
and maybe even Karen Page too, or at least
she wasn't a big part of the series when they started.
hopefully them rebooting.
Everything has changed that a little bit.
Punisher is coming back in a really big way,
even though there's some Easter eggs
in the last big ego trailer
like nobody goes unpunished.
That sounds like a very Punisher
kind of statement to make.
there's only five Echo episodes and she goes back
to her Choctaw Nation for a big part of it,
which is why I'm not expecting a ton of Punisher stuff
because I think he's still in the New York City area.
but part of the idea of a kingpin during Daredevil
born again is the winds up running for mayor
and becoming the mayor of New York City
at least at some point during the series.
and is supposed to be running
on an anti vigilante campaign.
So when he wins office, he basically uses
the police aboveboard stuff during the light of day
to try and get rid of all these quote unquote,
vigilantes like Daredevil in Spider-Man, for instance.
basically spinning things so that he kingpin
seems like the good guy, daredevil, Spider-Man.
These vigilantes like Punisher, for instance, seem
like the bad guys,
we'll probably get a couple other trailers
before the series actually drops.
Hopefully they dropped the nice shiny
HD version of this Daredevil versus Echo fight too.
but have you any of the questions about what's going on
during Echo or Daredevil born again
or what's happening with the Punisher character
Just write them in the comments below
and I'll add that to my future bonus videos.
they just dropped the what if season three trailer.
You can click here for that and you can click here
to learn all about Spider-Man 4
and him teaming up with Daredevil
during that against Kingpin
Thank you so much for watching
Happy New Year, everyone,
and I'll see you guys in the next one!